For a long time Speaker 1: The American right
wing has been
Speaker 2: using their
Speaker 1: narrow and myopic, cartoonish,
outdated view of masculinity and femininity
to attack anybody they can on the left.
Of course, you might remember back in the
2004 presidential election a big narrative.
A big movement was feminized.
Speaker 2: John Kerry John Kerry
Speaker 1: was the Democratic presidential
nominee in 2004, running against George W.
Bush, who was the Republican running for reelection.
And the story was Bush's masculine.
He clear his brush with a chainsaw in Texas.
He throws a baseball well.
And on the other hand, the storyline from
these right wingers was John Kerry is feminine
because he wind surfed, spoke French.
Imagine speaking.
Another language now is feminine.
And one sort of fumbled the football that
was thrown to him.
Speaker 2: And of course, this in and of
Speaker 1: itself didn't really fit the facts
the facts were.
Kerry was the military veteran who served
in combat in Vietnam.
Bush was able to be barely involved in the
military
Speaker 2: thanks to family connections by
their own
Speaker 1: standards.
Kerry should have been seen as the masculine
one, but it didn't matter.
The tactic is you feminize
Speaker 2: the person in the Democratic Party,
but OK,
Speaker 1: that was 2004.
We hadn't really seen this tactic during COVID,
Speaker 2: except for the occasional
Speaker 1: wearing a mask is
Speaker 2: gay type of stuff
Speaker 1: that we've previously covered on
the show.
They are now really upping the ante on that
talking point.
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson, during
an interview with British right winger Nigel
Farage, said that getting COVID not getting
the vaccine, getting COVID, you get sick with
COVID it, feminize you.
It makes you more like a woman.
Let's take a look at the clip quality.
Speaker 4: We're going to go, Yes, we're going
to go with climate hell.
And here's why we want to do it, and we invite
you the public to come with us on that journey.
That is leadership.
And Boris, just with the best one in the world,
doesn't have that.
And we've seen more U-turns in policy from
the Johnson government that I've seen in any
government in my lifetime and in a very embarrassing
way.
Some of it's been shocking.
So somebody who knows and told me and I should
be really getting your take on this, that
getting COVID emasculated him, it changed
him.
We had feminized women, weakened him as a
man.
Do you think that?
Well, I think he was very seriously ill for
sure.
He was.
I think one of the things we have learned
from COVID is people who are 50, 60, 70, 80
pounds overweight tend to have fared very
bad for sure.
Now we don't talk about it, but the virus
itself.
This is true does tend to take away the life
force.
In some people.
I notice.
I mean, it does feminized people and no one
ever says that.
But it's true.
I look, I think the virus did affect him,
but I think, let's be honest about it, it's
it's the new wife, isn't it?
I mean, it's, you know, Carrie Johnson or
as she's now called Carrie Antoinette, which
could be a story is like
Speaker 1: now, of course, if this is true,
if getting sick from
Speaker 2: COVID is feminine, all those right
wing radio
Speaker 1: hosts who denounced the vaccine
didn't get vaccinated ultimately got COVID
and died.
That's very, very feminine.
Speaker 2: By this metric that Tucker
Speaker 1: Carlson is laying out for us.
I actually got hit with this firsthand.
I don't know how many of you remember a few
years ago, I fainted on an airplane.
Sort of.
I fainted a few times in my life to sort of
a combination of dehydration,
Speaker 2: elevation, coffee,
Speaker 1: alcohol, you know, bad.
Combination of stuff, and when I told the
story, some people commented on YouTube, what
a sissy.
Speaker 2: And others said it was
Speaker 1: a medical event, you know, like
it's not, it's not feminine or masculine,
it's a medical reality.
And that's essentially the same thing that
Tucker is doing here now.
There's one other funny thing about this these
right wingers don't apply this standard to
their own.
None of them said feminized Herman Cain.
Speaker 2: What a woman.
Speaker 1: When he got covered and died, he
was a friend of Trump.
He was a Republican, a Jordan.
Peterson has been in and out of all sorts
of treatments for,
Speaker 2: what, two years now?
Speaker 1: I guess he's out now, but he was
Speaker 2: in for close to a couple of years.
Speaker 1: Hospitals in Eastern Europe, et
cetera.
They never said how feminine of Jordan Peterson.
Speaker 2: And in fact,
Speaker 1: he still had his fans and acolytes
hanging on his every word.
So as usual, it's a silly idea.
It's a dumb idea.
Disease as feminine is being sick as feminine.
But they also only apply it when it's convenient
to their narrative.
I actually do think maybe some of you would
disagree.
Major progress has been made on on some of
this stuff.
And fortunately, more of the population in
the U.S. don't see this bizarre, narrow definition
of masculinity as relevant.
You know, men hug more now in U.S. culture
than before.
It's been no big deal in most cultures.
For a long time in the U.S., there was more,
but that's gay man.
But it's diminished to some degree.
So I actually think on this particular issue,
Speaker 2: some progress has
Speaker 1: been made, but it still persists
in many, many places.
And as usual,
Speaker 2: it's the
Speaker 1: hypocritical application of these
standards that's particularly nonsensical.
So no real surprise.
I genuinely don't think Tucker believes any
of this stuff, and you and I meaning people
in the audience have called in before to talk
about this tucker for real.
Is he pretending the anti-vax stuff?
He's certainly vaccinated, right?
I'm sure all his family was vaccinated the
first day they became eligible.
Speaker 2: I don't know.
Speaker 1: But my instinct is, I think Tucker
is a terrible person because he's willing
to do this stuff.
But I'm leaning towards it's all B.S..
I don't really think he believes more than
half of these nonsense talking points that
he comes up with.
I think it's for the show.
I think it's performative.
I think it's for ratings, and that's nothing
I would ever do.
You all know if I tell you something on this
show, it's actually what I believe.
Let me know what you think you can find me
on Twitter at De Packman.
Speaker 2: Is Tucker for real with these
Speaker 1: talking points, or are they just
performative?
Also, remember that
Speaker 2: tomorrow is the
Speaker 1: last and final David Pakman Show
Viewer Town Hall of the Year, 6:00 p.m. Eastern
3:00 p.m.
Speaker 2: Pacific Tuesday,
Speaker 1: December 14th It'll be streaming
live on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
And if you want to participate, you can get
connected on The David
Speaker 2: Pakman Show Discord
Speaker 1: at David Pakman dot com
Speaker 2: slash discord.
Speaker 1: So I very gladly spent a bunch
of time this weekend setting up orders for
free David Pakman show T-shirts.
We made this offer last week.
I said, Folks, Sirs, M&Ms, children, everybody.
The last few months we've seen a little bit
of a decline in David Pakman show website
membership.
It's been a tough final few months of the
year.
We are offering
Speaker 2: free T-shirts
Speaker 1: to everybody who
Speaker 2: signs up for a
Speaker 1: new membership
Speaker 2: at the full yearly
Speaker 1: rate of $60.
A bunch of the emails I got were people who
just didn't understand.
Speaker 2: They said,
Speaker 1: OK, I just got a monthly membership.
Where's my T-shirt or just people that were
confused?
And but that's OK, that's par for the course
in this business.
Many of you did go and
Speaker 2: actually get full price yearly
memberships and ask me for the
Speaker 1: T-shirts, and we are pumping them
out and let's extend the offer for this week
as well.
You sign up at join Packman dot com at the
full yearly price of $60.
Full yearly price of $60.
You're a new member.
Email info at David Pakman dot com and we'll
get that free T-shirt right out to you.